all right guys this is a big one the cs
go scene just got rocked by a gigantic
cheating scandal and no i'm not talking
about a bunch of nobodies getting caught
hacking in the fpl
this happened at the highest level of
competitive counter-strike
and three coaches were banned and on top
of that there's been a second
investigation
with up to potentially 15 different
cases of match fixing
happening at the semi-pro level yeah
it's been a rough month for
counter-strike
[Music]
all right so for a while now we've been
streaming over at twitch.tv slash the
score esports with our talk show clouded
and if you love the stories that we
cover here on don't at me well you're
gonna love some of the conversations
that we have over on twitch we break
down some of the biggest stories
from esports and streaming and we talk a
little [ __ ] while we're at it
so make sure you follow the channel and
hit that notification button so you know
exactly when we go live
and hey you can watch me get roasted for
two hours straight
the news of this cheating scandal broke
a day after esl one cologne
finished esl published an investigation
and they say
quote we were made aware that by taking
a combination of different
steps a bug in cs go allows the coach of
a team to become a spectator anywhere on
the map
unbeknownst to anyone else end quote so
yeah this coaching exploit as it's being
called basically allows a coach to place
themselves anywhere on the map
and then swivel their camera from side
to side and theoretically take any info
that they gather from that
and give it to their players it's
basically one
giant broken cipher cam like invalorent
i mean
check this [ __ ] out now the bombshell at
the heart of esl's investigation
is the fact that they've proved coaches
from heroic
mibr and hard legion all use this
exploit at multiple different esl events
leading up to esl one cologne yeah three
teams competing at the highest level of
counter-strike
cheated in the investigation esl said
that the exploit violated quote
section 6.105 use of bugs and glitches
end quote of esl's rulebook to be very
clear
esl says that all of this happened prior
to the start of esl one cologne
and that in fact the exploit was
actually patched out prior to the
tournament starting
and so these rulings are the result of a
long investigation that just
happened to be published at the same
time that esl one cologne was finishing
the investigation
also says when and at what tournament
the coaches abused the exploit heart
legion's coach mechanogun used the
exploit at esl one road to rio
on six maps in three matches heroics
coach hundin used the exploit at
dreamhack master
spring in 10 rounds on one map and
mibr's coach
dead used the exploit at esl one road to
rio in one round
on one map and on thursday september 4th
former nip
coach peta admitted to abusing the
coaching exploit during an epl match
against mousesports
back in 2018 and like i mentioned off
the top these aren't just some
punk teams cheating their way through
fpl or some [ __ ]
this is the highest level of competitive
counter-strike
it's coaches and players competing
amongst the best of the best
and being found guilty of cheating in an
online tournament
with a prize pool of 350 000
on top of that heroic managed to win the
european portion of esl one cologne
and they looked [ __ ] great doing it
dominating some of the best teams in the
world
imagine going from heroes to cheaters in
the span of 24 hours
and the way we know about this exploit
and the fact that coaches have been
abusing it over the last few months
is thanks to freelance esports referees
mikael slowinski
and steve dudenhofer they spent dozens
of hours pouring over
thousands of different demos and
meticulously documenting any time that
they thought the
exploit was being used a big props goes
out to those guys
now unfortunately coaches abusing this
exploit is not
limited to esl events beyond the summit
recently put out a statement that says
basically that dead the coach for mibr
was found guilty of using this exploit
and beyond the summit
6. and the most damaging part of the bts
statement is where they said that
dead explicitly knew how to fix the
exploit
and continue to abuse it anyway quote
dead demonstrated he knew how to fix the
glitch while maintaining competitive
integrity prior to cs summit 6 online
by requesting a technical timeout
disconnecting and reconnecting
which happened in the may 1st of match
versus mv at esl one road to rio
end quote and then from there they go on
to say that quote
dead knowingly abused the coach
spectator glitch to obtain an unfair
competitive advantage
in mibr's lower bracket round three
match versus triumph
at cs summit 6 online on june 23rd
end quote yeah that whole give him the
benefit of the doubt type thing
goes out the window on this one now as
you can imagine the punishments handed
down in the response online was both
fast
and fierce here's esl's punishments for
all three coaches
heroics hunden is banned from competing
and coaching in esl events for a year
mibr's dead is banned for six months and
hard legion's meccano gun
is banned for a whopping 24 months or a
full
two years on top of that all three teams
will retroactively be disqualified from
the tournaments in question
while also forfeiting both their esl pro
tour points
and the prize money earned from those
tournaments man
esl is not [ __ ] around and beyond the
summit banned
dead from the next two bts events while
also retroactively disqualifying mibr
from beyond the summit six
and they basically have to forfeit their
prize money as well
now at the time of recording this hard
legion is the only team that's released
a public statement on the matter
and they basically said that they've
dropped meccano gun quote
yesterday we received a letter from esl
announcing the decision to ban our coach
for two years
it was difficult for us to believe in
alexander's guilt but we had to conduct
a personal investigation of this
situation
based on the results of internal
discussions we decided that the
punishment from esl was
fair we refuse to make any appeal and we
are staying on the side of the
tournament
organizer end quote and predictably a
lot of the responses from the cs go
scene online
are a whole bunch of you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
from pros to analysts to popular content
creators and of course brazilian fans
everybody is thoroughly pissed off and
honestly
people should be pissed off because
while this exploit doesn't involve
wall hacks or aim locks or some other
stereotypical idea of cheating
it still seriously undermines the
competitive integrity of cs go
the exploit gave certain coaches and
teams an unfair advantage
access to information their opponents
didn't have and they broke a rule in
esl's rule book
that's cheating now there's a ton of
speculation online right now and it's
got a lot of people
asking the big question did the players
know about it and while we don't have a
definitive answer
as to whether or not the players on the
teams that were caught cheating
knew about the exploit we do have a
partial answer from the esports
integrity commission
and the esic is basically an esports
watchdog they do their own third party
investigations
and then hand down their recommendations
to tournament organizers and in a
statement published on september 3rd
they revealed that
quote there is insufficient evidence
available to determine with any
certainty
that players were aware of any
wrongdoing or complicit in their coach's
behavior
end quote now to be clear that statement
doesn't necessarily mean that the
players knew
and what it does mean is that at this
point in time there's not enough
evidence to determine either way
now not long after the news of esl's
investigation and punishments was
announced
another scandal was breaking this time
regarding the mdl
which is cs go semi-pro league and i
first heard about this
from zelsis a pro player who took to
stream
and had this to say about potential
match fixing allegations
jordan do you want to do you want to say
it who did it
do i want to say what like nerve dance
esports
[Music]
what do you mean wait nerfed
after that clip blew up a ton of notable
names in the cs go scene including flam
asked zelsis to explain himself further
and to provide any proof that he had of
these mdl match fixing accusations
and it gets even worse because on top of
that the esic
recently announced that they've been
conducting an 18
month long investigation and they've
found possibly
15 different instances of serious match
fixing in the mdl
quote approximately 18 months ago and on
several occasions since
esic has received suspicious bet alerts
through our global integrity monitoring
framework
which has led us to establish an
investigation into potential match
fixing
activity in the mdl tournament series
administered by one of our members esea
as we consider this matter to be of
industry concern due to social media
speculation
we have chosen to provide an update as
we begin to finalize our investigation
end quote in a tweet announcing the news
they said that the investigation should
be wrapping up sometime in the next four
weeks
and at which point they'll give us a
final report and of course this set off
a fresh round of what the [ __ ]
is happening in the cs go scene online
one of the things to take into
consideration with this mdl match fixing
controversy
is the influx of mdl semi-pro cs go
players who've actually
switched over to valorent over the last
few months if it turns out that any of
those players are found guilty of match
fixing according to the esic
you have to wonder how punishments are
going to be handled understanding that
these players are now competing in an
entirely new esport and like if a player
is found guilty by the esic
of cheating or match fixing in cs go and
then they move over to valorant
is it up to the org that they sign with
to punish them
is riot gonna step in with some sort of
ban or
does nobody care and we just pretend
like this never happened
this is something that flam recently
talked about on his stream
i think nobody wants to build an esports
scene on players that have done stuff
like that so recently and quite
literally
in in preparation for your game i think
the ibuypower stuff was a very long
time ago but also you know and i i
think most people i'm not saying all of
you but i
i think there's you know people grow
there's time
people make mistakes that kind of stuff
if there's literally no punishment
like those guys literally served out of
punishment you know what i'm saying in
chat like
there what there there might not be any
for these guys like what
i don't know what the proper punishment
is at this point it would be a
giant understatement to call this entire
situation bad for the health of
competitive cs go
and it might be easy to say that with
both the coaching exploit and the mdl
accusations that who gives a [ __ ] it's
not like navi or astralis where they're
once caught doing this
but i think that as soon as you start
deciding what cheating cases are
important by who's involved
you're lessening the severity of what
this is and again to be very clear
this coaching exploit is cheating and
match fixing well
it's [ __ ] match fixing if we start
believing that cheating and match fixing
isn't a big deal unless there's huge
names involved
cs go is very quickly going to find
itself in a hole
it can't dig itself out of of course
there's always going to be people who
cheat and abuse
every competitive advantage that comes
their way but if it's happening at the
highest level of competition
in one of the world's biggest esports
we've got a serious problem
why did you buy this like weird like
like
round like thick water like that's so
impractical to hold
i know it's very impractical but i
[ __ ] love it i don't know why
but like on like like this i'll never
understand why
like like you know all these people that
could give you all this information
about things and you just go out and buy
awful products i was i was walking
through canadian tire and i saw this
thing it was a [ __ ] impulse buy so i
just [ __ ] i bought it
you know i don't even know why the [ __ ]
is that canadian tire to begin with
you're such a bad consumer it's like
incredible
how poorly you spend money it's got a
handle that i can like
[ __ ] use as a handle you know